[Music]
in hustling hikers news [ __ ] little
sweat nurse submitted by mudda education
that's another educational time give us
critical tart come on
a man was fine for illegally selling
certificates to hikers who made it to
the top of the Diamond Head hike in
Hawaii
oh it should go in cahoots with him oh
my god they should buy the idea from him
that's what their dinner like they're
like shushing a mouse
no they should start a chain like have a
guy that sells I ate garlic shrimp
t-shirts next to the Giovanni's like
after every big tourist stop you could
just spread out all these businesses
that I did this I saw Pearl Harbor shave
ice and I hate a man gone yeah already
things like that no I do you want a
picture and I'm like nah man I mean a
lot of people say yes okay I don't like
all like the hundreds of people that go
build it yeah you don't value memories
but if you do you would have liked it
yeah you right they always got the nice
border on them and [ __ ] too
what I do is take a picture of their
picture then post that when I'm going
down the log right I'm all confident cuz
doesn't scare me I look at the camera I
bought the pictures from when we went to
the macadamia farm I have it in the
office
there's no sweet yeah are we in it yeah
I think so I never seen no macadamia
fawn you guys didn't go oh then I don't
give a [ __ ]
oh I'm sorry that's you see it's better
I thought you were there oh I think we
have the we have the one where oh we
didn't go what the [ __ ] you guys didn't
go back a Damian yeah we did go yeah why
we listen to Joe glue out the luau one
blue outfit
the group photo oh no wait hmm oh my god
what enough but we don't remember [ __ ]
boring conversation oh why the [ __ ] the
macadamia who is this guy so this guy's
name is Christopher Barclay Christopher
Barnes I I you know what we've been
doing this a lot where we go in a circle
and try to remember some [ __ ] for like
10 minutes
you know that's you know that was just
all of you right now I wasn't the first
time as a third-party I'll tell you
exactly what happened
Davis started it and then he sat back
and just watched y'all just how about we
just not do that huh there's
observations I'm a facilitator of
conversation that's all I do
I wrote something and then you guys bite
and then we go somewhere and I think he
chuckles at one point you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
and a bar fight happens yeah all right
so yeah this guy Christopher Barclay he
has been selling these $5 certificates
to people who successfully for Berkeley
has a Diamond Head crater attention $5
$5 Oh
oh my god probably the second time he's
done it wow you yeah he has really thick
hair from when he shaves oh he does yeah
there's there's not a lot of skin in
there
he wasn't there was that [ __ ] sleep
oh [ __ ] it's like a diploma oh he does a
good job what's the problem that's done
I want one okay it wasn't when he got
caught later on in that video he got
caught because now all these people to
feel left out oh but did you get the
Diploma when you graduated the
Diamondhead
I want that diploma that guy's smart
yeah they look good too all right I
climbed that [ __ ] here we go no to be
100% honest with you you should leave
them alone because those diplomas
actually look dope as [ __ ]
yeah it looks better than they were on a
Chinese one and the Japanese one oh
that's Japanese in English languages
there's a gold leaf on it that's gold
leaf yeah he's got a gold feel and
everything and did you see the press
yeah oh my did Chris make me a maybe a
degree oh if I were Hawaii I'd be like
I'm taking a cut but now you're hired
all I know is that his Trek to work
sucks ass oh yeah it would be late every
day he deserves it his tractor what is
worth it all coming down up there yeah
that's all the top because I'm a long
ass time but there's a short way but
it's very hard errs it's called the
helicopter damn he's getting rich and
fit okay
kram it's like dude I was [ __ ]
traveller 50ms best wait I have to climb
a mountain to work you [ __ ] nah it's
sometimes it rains sometimes it doesn't
sometimes it doesn't
I bet you he doesn't work long I'll
leave him alone yes great
he's more long hours is she now he has
to pay two hundred and thirty dollars in
fines and fees and that's worth it so
the government is smart
just wait his damn thingy
no it was like a sea it was like a
predator make another one yeah
I want my certificate because I don't do
a lot of physical feats that require
height so that would been proof that I
did it oh yeah uh you have a youtube
channel bro I didn't record it oh then
it never happened
oh I did happen though I don't remember
no how do you see this see this is this
is why it would work I did it I did you
were there frame that you were gonna use
for your diploma that you never got
married so we didn't get a selfie
together on it you're on the vlog the
memories in my vlog oh yeah I did it I
also went up the the box mailbox
yeah PO Box is tight your Hollywood they
should have a certificate for all of
that and it's like now it's kind of like
you collect all these figures I want
your targets for different things but
like doing the laundry you know you're
gonna have so many certificates every
month I just want to feel proud when I
do it you know again what if it loses
its value like a receipt what about like
a good gift for laundry when you didn't
want to do it oh you should that you
don't know me I don't mind doing laundry
I just hate bullied yeah because you're
not even doing the laundry though yeah
it's the folding part this I know you're
acting like you [ __ ] sitting there
idea I did do it what what do you my mom
were gonna call my mom back in the day
we do the laundry she had the [ __ ] the
washboard
what did she had the crank where she
[ __ ] threw the laundry in that thing
it is squeezing wait
when she did her arm was the crank she
would do this little washboard yep I got
a mini washboard now and wash my own
clothes
dude those [ __ ] washboards just to
let you know that if you ever had a
[ __ ] t-shirt with a dope emblem on it
good luck or if you miss it and you're
scrubbing higher than you're [ __ ]
nothing good [ __ ] luck it's like
cheese no my brand new echo shirt
absolutely not because the Rhino got
ripped off I wonder how they used to
wash thongs the same way they wash that
know if we didn't have washing machines
if I designed a washboard I would have
some stinky kids I'd be like dip it and
go so--but water dip dip do part shower
with your clothes yeah that's right
that's absolutely right shower with your
clothes on like you got dumped or just
abort spray them down I know your guys's
laundry smells great by the way cuz you
got a Mexican lady that Mexicans use it
like a lot of softener yeah cuz when I
was when I was going in you softener I
do but then your guys it smells like a
constant one oh is it
yeah but the part how much he put a
spark okay so well not when we first
moved in together the Asian way it's one
sheet per batch right like that's how
that's how I was taught so I would put
one prior she's trying to save money
douchey and then so what I know when I
saw her do long like she she went right
this is what this is how I was taught
one sheet whatever her she went like
this dryer sheets come in like a pack of
a hundred so why not the first so I do
the last you washing found me III uh
at least you could do fine if you do too
many than your clothes waxy really yes
okay I did three for a full load like a
full doing this is my dryer time okay
but you Philip again with the box yeah
no no yeah you need the fabric softener
and the shoots because what I showered
at your guys the place I was like Oh was
I trying to rub it on my bodies when I
smell better I get like that cuz I love
the people when their laundry just
smells good oh it smells like a teddy
bear like a soft new teddy bear I do
launder this him I could teach you guys
I know how to do laundry softener and
the sheets cuz I used to do your laundry
you know the clothes though is that you
gotta [ __ ] get all the socks in the
boxers and everything they're all like
bunched up together and then you have
the piece of mountain I hate that [ __ ] I
wish when it's dry they just all
separate by themselves I washed my
clothes like one time last year when I
got in a fight with Jess and then to
make it up there was a lot of laundry so
I did all the laundry and I folded
everything and put it away
and then what she did is she took it all
out she washed it again to do it right
but I was sitting there for a minute
though like dude how do you [ __ ] use
this [ __ ] oh my god
I never washed anything since I moved in
I thought you were gonna say that you
did it out of spite like I don't need
you I know I was my way of saying I'm
sorry like thanks babe but you forgot to
you so like three sizes small what
happened to the white clothes in fall
she opens drawers
what the but you're still not sorry oh
so now you don't need me that's what
women do sometimes we just completely
misinterpret things that's all the time
because I want them to understand where
we're coming beause you're welcome to
come back anytime you do for that one
time you yelled at me in your dying wait
a minute wait a minute you can't just
drop that you gotta tell them the whole
story
nah sorry sorry y'all never like you
wake up and you're mad at your ex it was
like or your boyfriend cuz they cheated
on you were whatever I woke up I had a
dream that Gio yelled at me because I
was stealing stuff from her garden and I
got scared why she got a garden cuz she
Mexican no what did she do grow corn
specifically they were carrots and I had
a dream that I was mustered carrots pull
them up in the morning I was so scared
you were so scary and I texted you and I
was like I'm so sorry I just had a dream
that's so things from your guardian you
yelled at me you can't see see I never
really yelled at it okay yeah it wasn't
a dream
I'm sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]